أكثر ما يستفيد منه معظم الأطفال
من عطلاتهم الصيفية في هذه المجموعة هو
في مخيم الفضاء في دبي.
أذهلني الذي أقيم في مركز محمد بن
راشد للفضاء ، ويهدف المخيم الذي يستمر خمسة أيام
إلى تسخير الرحلات الفضائية المتزايدة الإثارة ،
فنحن نقوم بورش عمل
لعلوم الفضاء ، والكواكب ، والصواريخ
، والروبوتات ، وبعض المهمات القمرية ،
واستكشاف الفضاء ، وبناء الأقمار الصناعية
التي تعرف بعضًا منها.
يخضعون لتدريب على اللحام على
المستوى المؤهل للفضاء ، يقوم دافاي
باستثمارات كبيرة في تكنولوجيا الفضاء
الشهر المقبل ، أول
رائد فضاء إماراتي على الإطلاق سينطلق إلى الفضاء
في مهمة تستغرق ثمانية أيام إلى
محطة الفضاء الدولية ، وتخطط الإمارات أيضًا لإرسال
طائرة بدون طيار  مسبارًا إلى المريخ في 20 يوليو
حتى استعمرت الكوكب الأحمر بحلول عام
سلسلة من المشاريع الطموحة للغاية التي
تتصدر العناوين الرئيسية  لقد استحوذت
على خيال الطلاب وأظل
أخبرهم أنني سأراكم يا رفاق بعد 10
سنوات 15 ، نعطي هذه الفرصة
لهؤلاء الطلاب لهؤلاء الأطفال الصغار
للتعرف على الفضاء للتعرف على العلوم
والتكنولوجيا وعلينا
إشراكهم وإشراكهم  مع أحدث
التقنيات في الفضاء وهذا ما
نقوم به في Space Camp ، هذا
هو المستقبل ، لذلك نحن في الواقع
نعد الفريق الذي سيقود
المستقبل في هذا البلد ، المستقبل هو
طلاب مثل Matt I want to talk to
حول الحصول على وظيفة هنا بمجرد
التخرج ، أريد أن أصبح رائد فضاء
لأفيد البشرية ومواطنوها حميد
في مهمة ومن يدري ربما
يومًا ما سيقود الجيل القادم إلى
وجهات غير معروفة
وهي باستيان سيينا